der rest hat sich komplett verändert und
ich sehe immer noch aus wie 12
so jetzt kann ich nur sagen haltet euch
fest das ist wirklich finde ich das
krasseste jetzt was mädchen angeht oder
was mir halt geschickt wurde
so und jetzt 3 2 1 beim krassen zack
zack ist genau jetzt willkommen bei
einem neuen video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht's gut ja heute geht
es um ein video die idee habe ich auch
schon länger ich bin irgendwie noch nie
so wirklich zuge kommen und zwar habe
ich letztens mal auf instagram so ein
video gesehen darunter halt sehr viele
personen gezeigt wie sie vor der
pubertät aussahen und nach der pubertät
ist ja ganz normal jeder mensch kommt
irgendwann mal in die pubertät ich hoffe
ich auch bald
manche natürlich schon eher mit zwölf
manche vielleicht auch ein bisschen
später mit 1415 und da verändert sich
einiges zum beispiel die stimme wird
tiefer und so weiter aber die pubertäre
auch ein wahnsinnig großen einfluss auf
die veränderung des aussehens ich habe
personen gefunden die sind eigentlich
gar nicht mehr wirklich wieder zu
erkennen weil man sich so enorm
verändert vom vom typ her
das ist natürlich auch bei den einen
mehr ausgeprägt bei den anleihen weniger
also wenn ich euch jetzt mal ein foto
von mir ein brände wie ich früher außer
das foto das hängt hier oben herzlich
schwer zu sagen ich glaube da war ich so
13 und an sich hat sich bei mir jetzt
nicht wirklich viel verändert glaube ich
ich sehe vielleicht ein bisschen älter
aus aber ich bin jetzt kein
vorzeigebeispiel dafür dass ich extrem
was getan hat aber so gut ich habe jetzt
ein bisschen bartwuchs aber obendrein
vernünftigen bat bei mir zu kreieren
dauert es auch ein bisschen deswegen
sieht man jetzt nicht so den großen
unterschied aber ich kann euch
versprechen ihr werdet verblüfft sein
was ist gibt ich habe euch im instagram
gefragt ihr könnt mir gerne fotos von
euch zukommen lassen einmal vor der
pubertät und nach der pubertät das haben
einige von euch gemacht deswegen jetzt
nochmal hier der aufruf für den nächsten
tag vielleicht könnte man ja mehrere
partys machen wenn ihr darauf bock haben
dass auf jeden fall meinen daumen
oben da ich sag mal bei 8006 machen wir
das noch mal und schickt mir auf jeden
fall bei instagram alex wie fotos von
euch und jetzt haben wir gar nicht lange
sondern anfang an mit dem ersten foto so
das erste foto ist von einem mädchen
irgendwie habe ich fast nur mädchen ja
auf jeden fall ist es einmal das hier
sie trägt da eine brille
ihre frisur ist jetzt wie soll ich sagen
nicht meine lieblings frisur also da
sieht man halt ein mädchen was so keine
ordnung in die vierte klasse geht oder
so und dann hat sich dieses mädchen so
verändert und ich finde bis auf die
kopfform sieht man da wirklich überhaupt
keinen unterschied mehr
das ist eigentlich so krass war hätte
ich mir als jemand gesagt hey das ist
die dann würde ich sagen wann hast du
irgendwas vertauscht aber wenn man mal
nachdenkt kann das halt wirklich seien
verletzt bist du hässlich und wenn man
mich jetzt anschaffen
das ist nicht so arrogant oder was soll
ich denn gesagt
[Musik]
also sorry für den versprecher ja das
war so das erste beispiel finde ich auf
jeden fall echt heftig deswegen wenn ihr
zu zwölf seit oder 13 ihr könnt echt
gespannt sein wie ihr euch noch
entwickelt wenn ihr euch nichts nur so
wenig entwickelt so willkommen zum
nächsten foto das wurde mir glaube ich
geschickt bei installieren und zwar
haben wir einmal das mädchen auch mit
brille hat irgendwie früher jeder eine
brille getragen hier sieht eigentlich
ziemlich sympathisch aus ja auch ein
jüngeres mädchen hatte da so weiche
gesichtszüge sag ich mal und wenn man
dann jetzt rüber switch habe ich mir
wirklich gedacht ist zwar jetzt nicht so
brutal krass aber es ist auch schon
extrem heftiger unterschied ich meine
ich kann euch die fotos mal kurz
nebeneinander zeigen und da ist
eigentlich gar nichts mehr gleich nicht
mal die kopfform finde ich und hat auch
keine brille mehr
da hat man nicht irgendwie eher später
als früher man die das fahrwerk ändern
also das finde ich auch wirklich sehr
krass so leute kommen wir zum nächsten
foto die haben wir einmal die julia
glaube ich ich weiß es nicht kann auch
sein dass ich da ist irgendwas
durcheinanderbringen auf einmal auf
jeden fall eine brille
eine dritte früher so und jetzt kann ich
nur sagen haltet euch fest das ist
wirklich finde ich das krasseste jetzt
was mädchen angeht oder was mir halt
geschickt wurde willst auch mal sehen
ja jetzt ist schwer das zu dringen so
und jetzt 3 2 1 beim krassen sagt das
finde ich wirklich recht heftig ich
würde mal sagen hier war sie so 11 und
hier ist jetzt so 17 oder so da kann man
auch einfach gar nichts mehr
wiedererkennt das foto von damals ist
auch eher schlechtere qualität aber
hätte ich jetzt auch gesagt das ist auf
keinen fall diese person und dazwischen
liegen jetzt vielleicht ja höchstens 45
jahre bevor wir jetzt mal zu den jungs
kommen möchte ich euch gerne noch ein
foto zeigen was ich bei google gefunden
habe und zwar haben wir hier ein mädchen
einmal früher da stell dir auch unten
rüber wie vor heißt ja halt nur was wie
befour ich war halt irgendwie so ein
streber mädchen für mich guck mal was
hier kann es mal prozent die hat
natürlich wert ist anders gedacht auch
eine brille aufhaben früher irgendwie
alle kids eine brille und so auf jeden
fall haben wir die hier einmal früher
und jetzt haltet euch ebenfalls nochmal
bitte fest das ist auch so erhofft und
so keine ahnung da ist ja auch gar
nichts mehr gleich wenn man das jetzt
immer wieder nebeneinander auf zeigt es
kommt natürlich auch immer ein bisschen
schminke dazu ja hier ist jetzt
natürlich geschminkt aber dass aus
diesem wo ich eben gesagt hat streber
mädchen ich will jetzt natürlich auch
niemanden angreifen oder so aber das war
ja früher dass sie sich halt so
verändert also keine ahnung denkt man
halt irgendwie nicht ja ich finde es
irgendwie immer trauriger dass ich mich
habe ich noch vernehmen
ich habe mich irgendwie nicht so
wirklich finde ich mich ja vielleicht
ein bisschen
[Musik]
ihr könnt ja aber in die kommentare
schreiben findet ihr ich habe mich
verändert oder nicht so wird noch
schnell ein foto was ich über instagram
zugeschickt bekommen wir haben wir
einmal das mädchen architekt war und
hier haben wir sie als sie 17 war sie
ist jetzt wohl 17 finde ich auch echt
krass nur wenn man sich jetzt mal auf
das gesicht konzentriert ja ich habe mir
noch einmal das bild von früher und
daneben das bild von heute finde ich vom
gesicht her kann man das noch krass
erkennen also das war meiner meinung
nach bei den anderen jetzt nicht so bis
auf bei der ersten er schöne grüße an
die ich danke für die einsendung des
fotos und jetzt kommen wir noch zu ein
paar jungs wenn ich habe ja schon mal
früher gesehen deswegen kleinen moment
wollte jetzt kann heute eigentlich mal
die kosten zwar bin ich am samstag in
griechenland und ich habe mir
eingestellt um schöne aufnahmen zu
machen das ist jetzt mal überhaupt nicht
das thema aber ich packe das jetzt
einfach mal kurz live aus geht ganz
schnell wenn ihr da keinen bock drauf
habe
es gibt einfach 30 sekunden oder so das
problem ist akut sind noch nicht
aufgeladen aber so sieht das aus hier
kommt die kamera drauf und dann kann man
damit schon film yo leute noch ganz kurz
nachträglich schnecker das video was ich
noch vergessen haben zu sagen und zwar
bin ich jetzt am wochenende in
griechenland und ich habe so eine reise
kanal so als praktisch zwei kanal oder
so er ist einfach mal unten in der video
beschreibung verlinkter sind auch schon
ein paar videos dort kann nicht mal
kurzen ausschnitt zeigen
wären wir ja cool wenn ihr den noch
nicht kennen geht einfach mal drauflos
labor da würde mich sehr freuen
und sorry für die lange störung aber
jetzt können wir weitermachen
ich würde im video ja gut das legen wir
uns erst mal wieder kurz zur seite
denn wir sind ja noch bei einem ganz
anderen thema und zwar machen wir weiter
mit einem jungen ich habe leider nur
einen jungen foto weil das problem ist
immer wenn ich sage ich schick dir gern
mal ein foto von euch auf instagram oder
so kommen zu 95 prozent nur fotos von
mädchen
das finde ich schade aber ist halt
irgendwie so deswegen haben wir hier
einmal den jungen früher und zwar muss
sich das bild leider von google nehmen
ich habe es irgendwie gefunden ich
glaube das ist irgendwann promi keine
ahnung einmal früher die die ihn kennen
werden den jetzt wahrscheinlich noch
nicht erkennen aber früher sah er aus
wie sollen keine ahnung da jetzt in der
kann von frühjahr zu jetzt seine harfe
wollte sich einfach komplett verändert
und wir haben einfach mal jetzt und er
hat jetzt einfach schwarze haare
früher hatte der orangen haare früher
sah er aus wie ein tobias heute sieht er
aus wie sohn james oder so nur das ist
leider der einzige junge finde ich aber
auch echt klasse und ich würde sagen 1
geht noch und zwar haben wir hier einmal
ein foto von dem mädchen früher mit
brille mit brille
hey ich glaub ich nenne ich glaube im
kindergarten tragen 95 prozent der
kinder eine brille okay da grinst sie
mit den milchzähnen die kann man dann
haben wir jetzt einmal das wild und die
veränderung finde ich ja auch fast das
einzige was ich ähnlich finde ist die
nase
der rest hat sich komplett verändert und
ich sehe immer noch aus wie 12
nein so schlimm ist auch und ja leute an
den stoff oder hab ich noch bekommen und
zwar haben wir hier einmal die person
früher und daneben haben wir die person
heute und das finde ich ist auch extrem
krusty hat sich finde ich auch total
verändert kann ich jetzt eigentlich das
gleiche sagen wie zu den personen davor
deswegen gibt euch das und sei nicht
allzu traurig wenn ihr euch nicht sogar
zwei hinter kraft soviel zum thema ich
hoffe dass wieder durchgefallen wie
gesagt schickt mir gerne hat fotos von
euch zu über instagram alex wie heiß ich
davon wird auch gerne also gefallen
lassen doch nach oben dafür noch ein
paar und wir sehen uns eventuell
morgen wieder obwohl morgens feiertag
keine ahnung mal sehen ich wünsche euch
ein angenehmes langes wochenende
vielleicht und ja hat rein